i think of the two of us i am the the  definition of the very online person i  i spend  most of my time scrolling and you you  have a much healthier uh lifestyle yeah  that picture that saturdays has already  brought up this is the the team that is  currently leading in the olympiad  and this is honestly probably a  reasonably recent picture  i don't know exactly when it was taken  but it's  i would say maybe i don't know five to  seven years ago  not more than that  and i also have this feeling that uh  you also played i think we played  together in the tashkent video grandpa  in 2012 yeah which is exactly 10 years  ago yeah and i have the feeling that  actually we might have also had a big  impact i mean of course basically ruslan  kasim janov's uh success brought that  grand prix there to tashkent  and maybe this guy i mean for example  abdul sator was what he was like seven  years old at that time yeah maybe it was  the moment when he started